sar nicholas ii of russia was famously
unliked by bolshevik revolutionaries in
1918 over a year after he'd abdicated
the throne and given that prior to this
kings that had lost their thrones in
times of turbulence didn't exactly have
long life spans why didn't he try to
make his escape and head for safe shores
why didn't sar nicholas ii flee russia
for context in 1917 the russian empire
was fighting through the nightmare that
was the first world war and things
weren't exactly going well russia had
suffered millions of casualties it had
lost territory to the central powers and
on the home front things weren't great
either and when combined with
generations of displeasure at the
quality of life in russia it meant
revolution this first revolution
culminated in nicholas ii abdicating the
throne and his brother also refusing to
take it this came after a lot of
pressure from politicians and after this
nicholas was simply a russian citizen
free to do as he chose well for about
two days you see nicholas and his family
were arrested shortly after his
abdication on the orders of the new
government its leaders knew that the
people of russia were furious at the
former suffrage conduct during and prior
to the war and there were concerns that
the romanovs would be killed by a mob
unless they were arrested and so house
arrest had to do so what about simply
getting rid of the sarah moving him to
another country well given the ongoing
war the anton now had a problem britain
france and italy only cared for one
thing keeping russia in the war and
tying up the central powers in the east
and so they were sure to be friendly
with the new government whilst also
making it clear they didn't want the
tsar murdered and there were those in
the russian government from the
socialist revolutionary party in the
cadet party who were worried about
monarchists overthrowing the new
government to restore the tsar as such
there were two options try him imprison
him and risk him still being used as a
rallying point for monarchists in the
country or exile him and make him
someone else's problem the government
opted for the second one france didn't
want the romanovs because nicholas the
second's wife was german and france was
not exactly in a loving germans kind of
mood at the moment italy couldn't take
him because getting him there safely
would be too difficult which left only
britain which was fortunate because
nicholas's cousin king george v had just
offered him asylum in the uk and so
you'd think he'd have simply left russia
and spent the rest of his days in
britain but fun fact no you see very
shortly after britain had made the offer
it unmade it at the behest of the king
george didn't want to abandon his cousin
but across the uk nicholas was despised
and with the rising popularity of the
labour party there he didn't want to
give anti-monarchists anything to use
against him but beyond this there was
also simply the issue of pragmatism
there was simply no way to get him out
of the country nicholas was being held
here and he would have needed to head to
either archangels or to the newly
independent finland to get out the
finnish government didn't want him and
the workers at the docks in arkhangelsk
were overwhelmingly pro-bolshevik a
group of people whom the provisional
government needed to placate and avoid a
civil war with who also wanted the tsar
tried and so getting him out of the
country would have been nearly
impossible and the downsides of him
getting caught would have been too great
and as such the provisional government
took a brave step they did nothing and
they left nicholas under house arrest
until the bolsheviks took over who then
realizing a trial would like take time
or something just shot it
i hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly moneymaker mr wolf sky
chappelle adam stalter jordan longley
rod d martin gareth turner wyan hockey
jerry landon spencer lightfoot corso
wolff boogery wiggly marvin cassar
winston k wood gustav swan marcus asner
aaron the white matthew shipley robert
wetzel alex schwinn maggie paxkowski the
mcwhopper anthony beckett coppertone
spinning through plates charles the
first ben evanson scottish trekkie and
words about books podcast